Hello.
You like my little chicken?
My tiny chicken.
A little chicken on my head.
I am the chicken chucky now.
So I'm really tired.
I'm so fucking tired right now.
Doki chucky.
I'm sorry guys.
I'm sorry for the late stream.
I'm sorry.
Okay, so I'm not hungover.
I'm not hungover.
It's because...
Okay, the reason why I'm late is because...
I said it in chat, but...
It's the time of the month.
It started last night.
Right after the other stream.
The Mariva stream.
And like, I don't know you guys know.
Okay, so here's a little fun fact.
Woman!
Yeah, like...
So...
Okay, so here's a little fun fact for people...
For the people out there who, you know...
Don't have that...
The lucky individuals that don't have to go through this every month.
But basically...
If you mix alcohol with it being when the blood moon rises...
It's not good for you.
And occasionally...
You lose more blood when you drink.
So...
So the timing couldn't be more worse than...
The timing couldn't be more worse than...
Yeah, than it could be.
So when I woke up...
When I woke up today at 12.30...
I was like...
Am I alive?
I was just like...
I was like...
I was not okay.
And then I messaged my mom.
And I was like, can you change the stream?
I can't open my eyes.
Forgot.
Okay, so...
The thing is, for me...
Mine is super inconsistent.
It's never...
Stress levels affect...
Another fun fact for those...
It's so fun, guys.
Oh, man.
I wish you guys get to experience...
Some of you guys get to experience it too.
It's just the funnest time ever, guys.
It's so fun.
Man, I'm happy I get to do this every month.
Oh, my God.
I wish it happens every two weeks.
Oh, I'm having so much fun.
Anyway.
So, here's another fun fact.
Stress levels affect when it starts.
So, like...
It's so inconsistent.
Because I'm very stressed.
Sometimes I'm very stressed out.
So...
Sometimes it would be like, you know...
Two months.
Three months.
Like...
It's... I don't know when.
It's always a surprise.
So, like, when it happens...
I'm like...
Whoa.
It's just...
Surprise.
It's like, you know...
A little...
A surprise gift every time.
Whoa.
Happy birthday, Doki.
Surprise.
Don't you...
Ain't surprises great?
Whoa.
It's like, gotcha.
Yeah.
Raymond.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Skill issue.
No name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Pass, but you can keep trying...
But can you...
You can try projecting your pain to other...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Not so Deadpool.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Akasupa for your...
Okay.
That one was good.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Is there a calendar app or something?
I don't remember that.
It's irregular.
It's incredibly irregular.
I've like...
I've like stopped like trying to figure out when it's gonna be years ago.
It's...
You don't...
You don't know.
It's just...
It's always a little surprise every time.
I'll be like, oh, there it is.
The blood moon.
Woo.
It's just unfortunate that...
It's very unfortunate that it happened when...
At post-drinking.
Post-drinking because the moon haunts you.
Because like, that's like the worst...
The worst timing it could ever get be...
It could ever be.
So...
It's...
It's actually...
It fucks me up even more.
Because I...
I've never...
I've never been like this tired before.
No, I have been this...
I'm sorry.
My brain's not working right now.
I'm still waking up.
It's like revving an engine.
It's like...
I'm revving an engine right now in my brain.
But like, it's so difficult because it's like...
Oh my god.
You're not supposed to make...
You're not supposed to drink when it happens.
But like, of course it happens.
Like, of course...
Of course...
Of course it happens.
Oh my god.
How lucky can I get?
I already...
Bro...
I already got like...
Post...
Like, post-rival's depression.
And then...
You want more fucked up shit happening right now?
This last couple of weeks.
You're like, here, have this too.
Alright.
Alright, guys.
So...
Also, yeah, I ran out of...
I ran out of painkillers.
Actually, no.
I didn't run out of painkillers.
I never...
Actually, did I run out of painkillers?
Or I just never bought painkillers?
I don't know.
I just don't like...
I was like, where's my Tylenol?
And I was like, looking around.
And I was like, where the fuck did I...
I have Tylenol for, like, sinuses.
And I was like, bro, what?
I guess I never bought, like...
I never bought, like, regular painkillers.
I only bought, like, Tylenol and...
Tylenol for, like, fucking...
Like, fever and cold.
But never for, like, actual pain.
So I need to get a...
I need...
Okay.
And also, like, I usually never get cramps.
That's the thing.
I usually never get cramps.
So, like, it's really bad if...
The alcohol made it, like, a lot worse.
I was like, oh my God, this pain.
I don't...
I don't remember this pain.
I was like, it's been so long.
I was just like, oh my God.
It's been so long since I felt this pain.
Oh my God, the alcohol actually made it worse.
No!
Why?
The content!
Okay, anyway.
So, today...
Also, I hope you guys don't mind, but I have to tweet out the Call of Duty tournament thing.
Because, you know, when I woke up, I went straight here.
I woke up, I went straight here.
So, I need to tweet this out.
Because it's happening in three hours as well.
Okay, let's see.
I need to look at...
Sorry, I'm doing all of this live right now.
Alright.
Let's see.
Where is it?
Oh, yeah.
So, for those who don't know.
You know, like, it's funny.
They, like...
They made this image for me the draft day.
The draft day.
They're like, can we add your picture onto the thing?
And I was like, yeah.
And then they just...
They, like...
They inserted me into their, like...
Sponsor image thing.
So, like, they made this.
Which I thought was...
That was pretty cute.
I was like, oh, that's silly.
So, they're like, can we have a PNG of, like, you?
So, we can put it in.
And I sent the folder.
And then they just insert PNG of me here.
And I'm like, oh, that's cute.
I'm so out of place.
I know.
I was like, yay, three thumbnail.
They picked this one.
And they're just like, okay, here you go.
She looks so happy.
She doesn't know.
This was past Doki.
Looking forward to today.
A fun day today.
Nothing bad will happen to her.
Alright, let's see.
Today...
I'll see you guys on Twitch.
Twitch today at 4pm PST.
I have no idea what the fuck draft day is.
I should read the briefing.
I hope the sponsors...
Okay, the sponsors are not watching the Minecraft stream.
After this stream, I need to read the briefing.
I was going to read it yesterday.
But, obviously, yesterday I was not okay.
So, I shall read the briefing.
I shall read the briefing post this stream.
And then I should be okay, guys.
Everything will be okay.
I'm trying very hard to function right now.
Also, like I said, when I woke up, I went straight...
I usually would wake up early just to finish... just to prep everything.
But, like, I did not.
So, let's see.
Minecraft.
Because I'm launching Minecraft.
Okay, so apparently, it is on Bedrock for this event.
For those who don't know...
For those who don't know about the Minecraft Live...
A lot of people were like, what the fuck is the Minecraft Movie Live event?
So, the Minecraft Movie Live event is basically...
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god, it's so fucking silly.
It's to celebrate the release of the official movie, the Minecraft movie.
And it's basically a special event that will last up to, I think, like two weeks.
They extended it.
Oh my god, English is so hard right now.
I'm not hungover, I'm just... I might be low on blood right now.
I drank water, so my body is trying to create more blood.
My body is trying to...
My body is trying to create more blood right now to make up for it.
Anyway...
Low on oxygen, low on blood.
Okay.
Anyway, so it's basically a special server where you can meet Steve from the Minecraft Movie.
You can meet Jack Black and Jason Momoa from the Minecraft Movie in this event.
And then there's like special games and stuff.
And if you complete the little mini-games and everything...
Yeah, the real Steve!
Okay, I haven't watched the Minecraft Movie yet.
But like...
I've seen the dialogue from that movie.
And the fact that it's like, Let's mine.
Let's craft.
Let's Minecraft.
That might not be like the exact line from the movie.
But I'm just like, what the fuck?
Okay, what I really like about this movie...
Is that it's basically the newest Rocky Horror movie.
So people in the past...
I don't think a lot of people do it nowadays for Rocky Horror.
Because this was more of a 90s thing that had the cult following.
And so people used to do it where audiences would react to the movie and the lines.
And then react.
It was more like a performance type deal.
It's like audience participation.
The Rocky Horror show, yeah.
So people used to do that.
And The Room as well.
And I think the Minecraft Movie is the next audience participation movie.
Because when it came out, everybody was like...
Chicken Jockey!
But I think the only fucked up part about it is that...
There's also a lot of very egotistical and conceited children doing it too.
Who think there's no consequences.
So in the Rocky Horror movie show...
Sorry, the Rocky Horror show...
And The Room...
It was more so of acting around the movie itself.
And just, you know...
Costumes, wearing costumes.
And reciting the lines.
But for the Minecraft Movie, people are actually throwing popcorn around.
I thought at first it was really funny.
But it's been getting worse.
I saw people getting worse and worse.
And then, yeah.
Throwing the chicken one...
I was like...
Okay.
I didn't...
The throwing the chicken one was a little too far.
Because, I don't know if you guys heard...
About the...
The video about the chicken.
But the guy who did that...
Abandoned the chicken.
Right after.
I was like, what the fuck?
I was like...
Yeah, no.
He literally filmed himself...
Abandoning the chicken later.
And then, someone was like...
And then, people in the chat was like...
What the fuck?
And then, he was like...
Chickens get killed...
100 million chickens get killed every year.
For food.
This doesn't change it.
We're just returning the chicken to the farm.
And I was like...
What the fuck?
This guy is a fucking teenager, by the way.
A teenager slash young adult.
I don't know how old he is.
But he seems like one.
And I was like...
That is so messed up.
I was like...
Yeah.
Yeah, no.
It was like some fucking TikTok creator.
I was like...
Bro.
Yeah.
I was like...
What the fuck?
So...
At first, it was really fun.
But then...
People made it too extreme.
Because it was like...
They see other videos.
And they're like...
I'm gonna do it.
But do it something even bigger and better.
And then they just started...
Fucking throwing food around.
And throwing eggs at people in the movie.
And shit like that.
Because the first couple of videos were really funny.
You know?
Everyone was just cheering and clapping.
That shit was funny.
Chicken Jackie and everyone celebrating it.
It was like World Peace was fucking...
World Peace was announced.
And everybody was like...
And clapping and celebrating.
Jumping and hugging each other.
That shit was funny.
But then people just started throwing food.
And chickens.
And body slamming employees.
I was like...
That's not cool.
Because they wanted to be on...
They just wanted to be filmed for Haha Funny.
I was just like...
It was a funny experience.
But people just made it so much worse.
I really was looking for...
I wanted to watch the Minecraft movie.
At a theater.
Because I feel like if you watched it...
If you watched it in the beginning.
I think it would have been more enjoyable.
Because people didn't get too extreme now.
I think movie goers now are just trying to make it more and more...
Because they're like...
I saw videos.
I saw videos of this happening.
So now I want to do this and that.
I don't want to get popcorn thrown at me guys.
I just don't want to get popcorn or eggs thrown at me.
So I'm a little scared to go.
I don't know.
I might go to a VIP theater or some shit.
Because I feel like that would be more calm.
Rent the entire theater.
I don't know.
I was really looking forward to it.
Because...
Yeah, VIP.
Only the best for the...
Guys, only the best for the Minecraft movie.
Yeah, no.
That's the thing.
The reason why I was thinking...
Maybe I should go to a VIP movie theater.
Is because I was like...
Children can't be...
It has to be 18+.
Because a VIP movie theater...
Is basically like...
You can drink alcohol while you're watching a movie.
Which now I'm thinking about it...
Might not be the best idea.
Because you can literally order alcohol from the bar...
While you're sitting in your seat.
But you have to be 18 and plus to be able to go in.
So I was like...
Okay, maybe children won't be there.
I was thinking, oh man, children won't be there.
But then I'm like, oh no.
There's going to be a bunch of fucking drunk adults watching this.
Because I think everybody has the same plan as me.
They're like, we gotta drink to watch this movie.
So drunk college students...
So I don't know.
I don't know if it would be better.
But I just don't want popcorn thrown at me while I'm watching the movie.
I'm just not up for that.
I'm not really into that, guys.
Zero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Why not membership watch?
Oh man, actually I really would want to do a membership watch of the Minecraft movie.
But also like...
Oh wait, here's the live event.
Okay, let me...
Live event.
Ends in three days.
Join.
I'm joining the live event right now.
Download everything and join.
Okay, download.
I do want to watch it.
But then I really also want to watch an Athelier too.
I could watch it...
Decisions, decisions.
Next movie has...
Next watch has to be a good movie?
You promised.
Yeah.
Isn't Minecraft movie a good movie, guys?
But the Minecraft movie is a good movie.
What are you trying to say?
What are you...
What are you trying to say, guys?
Is it not a good movie?
Alright, let's see.
Alright.
Yeah, we won't stand for this slander.
Did I download it?
Wait, encountered an issue?
Wait, why did...
Is there an issue?
No, you can't do this to me.
Wait, no.
I want to meet Steve.
Let me meet Steve.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
I'm in.
Sorry, I have to hydrate.
I forgot I'm...
I forgot that I'm the Cheshire Cat.
Okay.
I'm the Cheshire...
Let me go to the dressing room real quick.
Let me change my skin.
Now I can be Sans.
Alright, let me be Sans Undertale instead.
Alright, yippee.
It's me, Sans.
Alright, resume game.
Hello, I'm here for Steve.
There's supposed to be a black screen?
Hello?
Oh.
What the fuck?
Hello?
Where my game at?
What the fuck?
Where is my game?
Where is my...
Okay, let me...
Okay, obviously there's some...
No, I want to meet Steve.
There he is.
Steve.
Oh, there I go.
Save the village.
Save the world.
Hello, everybody.
Oh, my God.
Where's the...
Wait, he talks.
Hi there, partner.
How are things going outside the village?
How's my...
Oh, my God.
Steve!
That's my pal Henry getting on.
I bet he's doing his...
Wait, there's...
There's actual, like, voice lines from Jack Black.
Wait, what the fuck?
Hello, Steve.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
It's the real Steve, guys.
There he is.
Oh, my God.
Steve.
Thank you, Mr. Steve.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh, my God.
Wait, how do I do emotes again?
I don't remember.
How do you do...
Oh, my God.
There I am.
Me and Steve.
Take pictures, guys.
Wait, how do...
Do you guys remember how to do emotes?
I don't remember.
How do I...
Guys, how do I do emotes, guys?
Is it B?
Alright.
Nice.
I just want to do this next to Steve.
Roll out.
Yippee.
I fucking...
Best fucking purchases of my life.
Oh, my God.
There's all the villagers.
There they are.
There's a little cat there.
I want to explore.
Let's see.
Is this all from the movie?
All of these?
Did he just say Flint and Steel?
I think he said Flint and Steel just then.
Oh, my God.
There it is.
There's chicken lava.
I can't believe...
Okay, if you get the...
Oh, my God.
There it is.
I got the chicken.
I got the lava chicken.
Get the fucking stupid lava chicken.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I'm fast.
Holy shit.
I'm so fast.
Look at me.
Oh, my God.
I was too fast.
Wait, there's...
Why is there a little piglet in here?
What are you doing here?
What are you doing?
This is not for you.
Get out of here.
You don't belong in the city.
Oh, he's gone.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
You don't belong here.
That's right.
This is a villager-only city.
Okay, so, like, for those who don't know, the official soundtrack for...
The official soundtrack for the Minecraft movie has, like, a 30-second segment of Jack Black singing the lava chicken song.
I'm just like, why?
Why?
Why is there...
Like, it's literally just 30 seconds of Jack Black being like...
Chicken, lava, lava.
Chicken, lava, chicken.
It's a good part.
Okay, you don't understand, Doki.
It was a good part of this movie.
Alright, what else is there?
Oh my god, there's a music room.
Wait.
You have to buy this?
Oh, that's where...
That's...
Oh my god, you can buy a sheep.
What do I do with the sheep?
Oh, that's where he got it.
I was like, oh, I thought it was, like, an emote.
Oh, this guy's been playing this for a while.
Wait, can you wear this hat?
Wait, did he buy a hat?
Oh my god, he did!
Wait, oh!
Oh, you can buy, like, cosmetic hats and everything.
Go to the bell tower?
Where's the bell tower?
Where is it?
Is this the bell tower?
I'm exploring.
It was so nice of them to put a small YouTuber.
Oh my god, he said the...
Oh my god!
Guys, he said the thing!
He said it.
Oh my god, it's like watching the movie right now.
It's like I'm actually watching the movie, guys.
He fucking said that thing.
Why do I have to go to a CD-R when I can just play this game?
No way!
I can't believe they put small YouTuber Jablinski Games into this game, guys.
Into this film.
If he can make it, anyone can make it, guys.
Alright.
Let's have a little duet.
With Hatsune Miku and Sans.
And then he jumped.
Do a flip.
Wait, what other stuff is there?
There's so many.
Oh, I guess these are all...
Don't worry.
This is our new duet together.
Oh wait, shit.
No, don't leave!
No, I didn't mean to eat my lava chicken!
Okay, let's see.
What do we...
Okay, so there's like different types of games that we can do.
And apparently, like, you get to...
If you accomplish the mini-games, you can get a free cape that you can only wear in bedrock condition.
But that's okay.
Oh look, Jason Momoa!
He's so out of place in here.
Why is he so tall?
Why does he look so...
Oh wait, no, he's the same size as me.
Ah, my new projects has arrived.
We're protecting the village walls from the piglins and we need our best fighters.
Think you're up to the challenge?
Let's go.
Is he taller than me?
No.
No, he just...
Why does he...
Oh, it's the waist.
I don't know.
There's something about him that he just...
It just seems like he looks taller than me and I don't know why.
Hello, Garrett.
Wait, I want to take a picture with you.
Give me a sec.
Alright.
Roll out.
Alright, Garrett, let's go.
Yes, I want to do it.
I shall protect the village.
Let me protect our village, Garrett.
More than meets the eye.
But I don't know if I want to watch the movie for a member stream or like...
Oh wait, the gate's already broken.
Wait, why...
Guys, I'm still in the cutscene.
Why is the gate broken?
Wait, that's not fair.
I'm like literally in the cutscene.
The more piglins you take down, the bigger your reward.
Oh, so like...
Oh my god, look, there's a guy with a sword.
Okay, so apparently I need to...
Wait, no, and then...
Oh, wait.
Who's in my army?
Oh wait, the gate's being broken right now.
Oh wait, that's bad.
Wait, can I die?
Look at all these guys.
You know...
Look at the one guy.
He's like, remember to use range.
And then there's this one guy that's just like, I don't need range.
He's like, I don't need that shit.
Come down and get me.
He's holding the line.
Yeah, he's holding...
He's actually holding the entire fort for us.
He's a real gamer.
Oh my god, wait.
We have like, golems that only get this one man to take on the entire world.
He's just built different.
Can we shoot each other?
No.
What's the point?
What's that?
Watch this.
Boom.
Look at that.
Fucking aim right there.
Even in Minecraft, I can aim.
Okay, ignore that.
Okay, but that shot was sick though.
Okay, ignore that though.
Oh, ow.
Okay, wait.
That's not fair.
They shoot back.
Oh my god, bro.
Oh my god.
Save him.
Bro, he's 1v5 right now.
Oh, that's just a golem.
I don't have to care about that.
Oh wait, but he's gonna kill him.
Let's see.
We can do it.
I'm just gonna save him.
I'm a hero.
I'm a fucking hero.
I need that XP too.
I need this XP.
No!
Mr. Golem!
He likes those odds.
Oh no.
Oh no, they're going for him next.
Run, golem, fight back!
Don't just stand there, fight back!
Oh shit.
Oh, he's coming here to sweep all those kills.
Where did he come from?
He's like, yoink my kill.
No, I need that one.
No, I need that XP.
Okay, I yoinked my XP.
Oh my god, I'm gonna kill a child too.
That's right.
Get out of here, child.
I need that.
Daddy needs a new cape.
Get out of there.
Jump down.
Guys, I'm not crazy like...
Guys, that guy has a fucking costume.
He's been doing this for the last two weeks, man.
Bro, this guy has been playing in the server for two weeks now.
Like, he knows what he's doing.
I'm just a little archer boy.
Don't be a hero, Doki.
That's fine.
I have this.
Oh no, they might get the gates though.
Wait, how long...
How long...
Like, look at him.
He has a fucking hammer.
Like, I...
How does...
Oh shit.
How does he have a hammer?
Bro, he has like this little...
Like, double hammer shit.
He's scary.
Wait, I should eat this.
I'll start playing music for everybody.
Guys,
I don't think...
I don't think they liked my music.
Alright, guys.
I shall play music for the crew.
Let's all play a battle song.
Let's go, everybody.
Don't worry, I shall be the bard.
I shall be the bard for this fight.
Oh shit, now there's...
Okay.
Wait, I actually shoot these down.
Protect the golems.
Okay, but like, what about some sick music though?
Okay, I gotta actually save and protect the village.
Alright.
Okay, now...
Wait, they have enchantments on their bows?!
Don't worry.
I'm here to motivate you.
Wait, am I actually barding it up for him?
Bum-ba-dum-ba-da-dum.
Okay, I'm helping, I'm helping, I'm helping.
I swear.
I swear to god, I'm helping.
I'm part of the team.
The support mindset.
I'm helping now, guys.
I swear.
I swear, I'm part of the team, guys.
How long is this mini-game?
On some days, piglins or players will be buffed.
Oh, so like, some days it would be like, stronger.
We do a little trolling, just a little.
How long does this game mode end?
Can I just play music?
Oh, I guess like, it ends as much as you want to farm infinite.
Oh, there's an end?!
Wait, there's no end to this, so how do I leave?
Can I just leave whenever?
Can I just leave this army and desert them?
But like, how am I gonna get my Minecraft cape?
Wait, I'm stuck here forever?
But how do I get my Minecraft cape?
How do you finish this?
Wait, he's playing his little funky music.
Oh my god, no.
I killed him.
All he wanted to- Is that a gun?
How do you have a gun?
How do you have a gun in Minecraft?
Okay, quest.
Okay.
Wait, what is it?
Defend- Help each of the characters get the boot of swiftness wrestling room.
Um, ways to defend- Oh, I just have to defend at least- Oh, okay.
It's okay.
I did one of them.
Wait, wait, wait.
Quest.
Oh, shit!
Wait, I can just exist.
They can defend for me.
I'll- I'll- Don't worry, guys.
I got this.
Don't worry- No!
Why do they hate music?
I don't understand.
Why do they hate music so much?
They get a warning sign.
They hate the part.
I just wanna play my funky song.
They target support first.
Wait, I think our knife guy quit his job.
I think he saw what I was doing.
Wait, what happened to knife man?
What happened to our- What happened to our barbarian?
Our tank?
He's gone.
He doesn't play for us anymore.
Our barbarian left.
Was it because of my music?
Did he not like my music?
I was born to be a bard, not an archer.
I just wanna play my music.
No, we lost our tank.
It's just a team full of archers now.
You were playing it in E minor.
No!
Oh shit!
Oh no!
Okay, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys.
Guys, I can't take any more damage right now, guys.
Can you guys like finish the job?
I just need one more wave left.
Oh my god, there's like a medic center and everything.
Don't worry, I think my team can defend this.
I believe in them.
I'm gonna explore the village.
Don't worry, I'm just healing, guys.
I'm just healing.
Oh my god, they're- Oh my god, they're mining in fact and order.
Oh wait, we're both exploring the village here.
Don't worry.
Oh wait!
Oh shit!
Oh wait, wait, wait a minute.
Wait, I'm supposed to defend- Oh guys, guys, go down here!
Guys, no!
I have sightseeing!
We lost our warrior!
It was not- I just wanted to explore.
I just wanted to explore the village.
It's okay, I just need two more- I just need them to defend two more- two more waves.
Guys, I don't know what happened.
We lost our tank and then everything went downhill somehow.
Somehow, like, apparently when your team comp doesn't have a tank, things just don't go as well.
This was my rank up game.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I'm going in.
I shall be the next barbarian.
Wait, how do I go in though?
Wait a minute, instructions unclear.
How do you go down?
Wait, were you not supposed to- Wait a minute, did that guy bug his way downstairs and he were actually not supposed to go downstairs?
Because, like, how do you get down?
Took his already- Oh, it's an explo- it's an explo- oh shit!
Oh my god, okay.
I don't pay attention to the fact that people want to kill me.
Alright.
Oh, I just gotta eat it?
How do I get in?
I ate the chicken.
I ate that chicken.
I wanna be part of the team.
How do I get in?
I'm eating it.
Where is it?
I wanna be part of the team!
Okay, I'll- I wanna- I wanna go down there!
I wanna be the next tank!
I wanna be the tank!
I'll be a hero!
Just like him!
Oh shit, oh shit.
Oh fu- Wait.
Oh wait, no, I'm back in, I'm back in.
Okay, sorry, I took fall damage.
I got- actually, I took fall damage.
Sorry, too late, guys.
It's not fair!
I just wanna go down there and beat people up.
Is that too much to ask for?
Get the bard.
If I can't play music, he can't play music either.
No one can play music.
Music is banned in this area.
Jason Momoa, save us.
Okay.
96 enemy kill, defense is 13%.
Guys, please protect the island, please.
No.
I don't think I will.
Why protect them when they can protect me?
I'm just trying to figure out how to get down.
He knows the strat- wait, okay, how do I- How do I, like, get downstairs?
Guys, I'm trying to glitch it.
I'm trying to glitch it right now.
I'm eating my lava chicken.
I'm playing my funky music.
Naughty is ignoring comms.
I'm not ignoring it, I'm choosing to not listen.
That's different.
The lower wall?
Okay.
Okay, we gotta get to the lower wall.
Guys, I see it.
I don't know how I'm trying to go down a ladder.
Oh my god, is it because of the lava chicken?
Let me- Guys, guys, I'm stuck.
Oh, there you go, there you go.
Alright, alright, how do we do it?
How do we go down?
I shall figure this out.
Guys, I'm not trolling.
I'm trying to be a hero.
But to be a hero, I must get out of the- I must get out of the- Find a corner?
Okay.
I must get out of this village.
Okay, find a corner.
Okay.
I'm finding a corner right now.
Let me in.
Let me in, let me in!
I wanna go out!
I wanna be an outside bird!
Let me out, let me at him!
Let me kill him!
Please!
I have the spirit!
Let me at him!
I'll shoot this guy.
Fuck this guy in particular.
Alright.
Fuck you.
Get down from here.
Nobody deserves to be in the sky.
Oh, I'm an outside bird.
I need outside.
Oh hey, another one.
Nice, $80.
I can't believe people have $80 just lying around like that.
Alright.
I'm bugging in.
Don't worry.
I'm helping.
The moment I get out, they will know.
Guys.
Is this not the lower ledge?
Oh.
Don't worry, I got this.
I'm here.
Guys, did we win?
Did we win, guys?
Okay, don't worry.
Next time.
This time, I got it.
The moment I figure out how to go outside, it's over.
Guys.
We just gotta figure out how to go outside.
This time, for sure.
Okay, this is upper.
Is this lower?
Is this here?
Oh, shit.
I might die.
Is it here?
I'm glitching.
Wrong side?
Oh, it's on the other side.
Okay.
Alright, let's go to the other side.
Alright.
Wait, wait, wait.
Is it here?
Is that, is that, was that it?
That's going so fast.
Oh, my God.
Okay, no.
Alright, no.
Still no.
Where is the lower edge?
Where is that?
Guys, I need a map.
I need a, I need an explore map, guys.
I won't be out there.
Where the mobs are?
Wait, what?
Oh, next to the gate.
Oh, here?
This guy, this random guy that's not doing anything?
Right here?
Oh, my God.
Where am I?
Right here?
No.
Face towards the enemy.
Oh, the bow.
Guys.
Instructions are very unclear right now.
Instructions are very unclear.
Guys, please.
Instructions very unclear.
I'm trying my best.
Oh, here.
I'm glitching.
Get me out.
Okay, our army is pretty bad, not gonna lie.
I'm trying.
Please.
I almost made it.
The moment I'm out of here, it's over.
I will sleep when I'm out.
Let me out.
We got to the one block.
Wait, isn't this block right here?
Oh, the center balcony.
Here.
Here, right here.
Oh, my God, this is it.
The moment I get out, it's over for them.
It's over.
Let me out of this invisible wall.
I don't care if I get hit.
Okay, maybe I do.
All right.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm going in.
The moment I get out, it's over.
The moment I'm out of this jail.
The moment I'm out of this jail, it's over for you.
Get me out.
Get me out of this invisible wall.
Oh, he didn't crouch.
Okay.
It's gonna be so over for you.
The moment I'm out of here.
Oh, my God, our poor fucking golem.
I'm just watching.
I'm watching this all happen to him.
Don't worry, sir.
The moment I get out of here, I'll help.
I swear to God.
Don't worry.
I'll be a hero soon.
Don't worry, sir.
I'll help you soon.
Guys, that's crazy.
Okay, I think our army might not be the best army.
Get down and help him.
Guys, I have important things to do right now.
As in, I have to figure out how to...
I'm trying to figure out how to glitch through.
Please.
Please, it's all I want.
I just want...
If only there was a bar to raise my morale.
If only.
Please, let me through.
Let me through this stupid invisible wall.
I am.
I'm crouched.
I'm so crouched.
It won't let me glitch.
I'm pressing every crouch button I have.
Oh, here?
Right here.
This one.
Is that one?
Is this one?
Get turned by the gate.
Oh, this one.
Oh, crouch after you start glitching.
Okay, okay, okay.
It's over!
It's over for you.
I'm stuck.
Oh, wait.
It's over.
I'm stuck in this one corner, though.
Don't worry.
I'll save you.
I'm just gonna get past the area.
I'm stuck.
I'll save you.
Don't worry.
Okay, I'm now stuck in this corner.
No, no.
I'm almost there.
So far.
Please, get closer.
Please, get a little closer.
Please, please.
Get a little closer so I can help out.
Guys, I swear to God.
Guys, I'm helping.
I swear to God.
Guys, I just need to figure out how to get out of this one corner, please.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Am I stuck here?
Oh, shit.
Guys, how do I get out of this wall?
As you said, I can get out.
How do I get out?
I can't.
This is my life now.
No, I can't leave.
It won't let me leave this.
Oh, it's open.
It's so open for all of you.
That's right.
I'm the tank now.
It took me five.
I watched five golems die for this.
I'm tanking now, bitches.
Get over here.
That's a cute wreck.
I am a hero.
He's dead.
You don't get to play music in my lobby.
Only I get to play music.
Oh my god, we gotta help this man.
Don't worry, I'm coming over to help you.
Oh man, there was no one there.
That was weird.
There was no one there, guys.
That was so weird.
Don't worry, the hero is here.
Wait, they don't know what to do.
This is actually crazy.
They don't know what to do.
They're like, you're not supposed to be out of the gates.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
Get out of here.
I shall be the hero the village deserves.
I ate so many chickens to get here.
That's right, leave.
Leave.
Watch this, though.
Is he doing it?
Oh, shit.
Okay, I should help him now.
Oh, no, don't die.
I'm sorry.
No.
I was playing too much funky music.
That music was too funky.
Don't laugh.
Look what you've done.
I'm sorry.
I just wanted to play some silly songs.
I wanted to be a bard.
I told mama I just wanna be a bard.
But mama said, no, you were born to fight like a man.
I'm like, mama.
But mama, look at this sick-ass tune.
Born in the wrong class.
Look at that.
I told you I can be a hero.
Did I finish my quest?
Oh, yes, I did.
And that's it, right?
Alright.
Is there anything else in my quest?
Gas killed.
Wait, piglin reinforcements have arrived.
Wait, do I get Steve?
Oh, I can get like a battle cry.
Wait, what?
Okay.
Enemies.
The fight.
Make sure it stays that way.
Oh, I get a mushroom hat.
What's number four?
Protect the traitor's route.
Oh, Cadouche.
Wait, I want the Cadouche emote, actually.
Wait, the Cadouche emote is pretty sick, not gonna lie.
Oh, I want a Cadouche.
Okay, to get the jetpack dressing room.
Way is cleared with at least two iron golems alive.
Oh, that's awkward.
That's pretty awkward.
Um, you know, maybe I should have stopped playing my music.
All right, you guys are on your own now.
All right, the tank is leaving.
Good luck.
The tank is leaving.
I'm going back home.
Wait, I could have tried the portals.
I forgot.
Oh my God.
Wait, yeah, you guys said the portals work, right?
No!
The tank left.
I forgot about the portals.
Okay, how's the sound, by the way?
Is the sound okay?
The tank has left the game.
Wait, I'm gonna try switching over again.
All right, don't worry, the tank is back.
The tank is back.
I know how to do it this time.
Get me in there.
Yes.
I'm ready to tank.
Now, the tank has left.
Now, what do we do?
I mean, this team fucking sucks.
It's just a team full of Widowmakers.
Like, what the fuck am I supposed to do with that?
Wait, the door didn't load in.
Oh.
No!
All right, I can do this again.
I figured it out.
Oh my god, the first try!
Look at that.
Okay, this one doesn't work.
For that first fucking try, guys.
Doing this, though.
Okay, not this one.
Does this one work?
Oh, wait, no?
Apparently, one of the portals work, right?
He'll figure this out.
Fuck you, though.
Get down from here, you don't deserve to be in the sky.
It's one of the small ones?
This one?
Oh my god, wait.
Am I going to the nether?
I just...
I just separately went to the nether.
Wait.
Am I generating a world in my... in the special worlds?
Oh my god, where am I?
Where the fuck...
Where the fuck am I?
I'm in a separate nether right now.
Wait, can I die?
Oh, wait, I can't die.
I actually generated some random fucking nether.
I broke...
I broke the world.
Wait, can I like...
Wait, I can't even die from the lava.
Can I mine any of this?
Wait, I can't... where am I?
Where did I... where did I go?
The gate...
Okay, but like...
Why the gate when I'm in this cool...
Why the gate when I'm in their home...
I'm in their home territory.
I'm in their base.
I'm trying to find their base right now.
I'm going undercover.
This is so much more important than the gate right now.
This is like...
Like I'm on an actual mission.
I'm invading their fortress.
I'm gonna be the one invading their homes and destroying their gates.
The after credits scene.
Can't believe I created the nether in this.
I wonder if there's like enemies spawning here.
I don't think it was meant...
I don't think they were like...
It was meant to be coded in.
Now this is just reg...
This is just regular Minecraft where I can't do anything at all.
We're gonna...
We're gonna find the fortress, guys.
Yeah, nothing is spawning here.
It's only just like buildings and stuff.
That's cr...
Wait, there's a gold block.
Wait, what the fuck?
I wanna get up there.
Wait, there's something up there.
Do you see that?
The fuck is that?
Where am I?
Swim up...
Wait, you're right.
I can swim up a lot.
Oh, wait, what is this?
Wait, that's a giant ass...
Wait, is that natural?
What is this?
Is this a ruined portal?
Why is the ruined portal so fucking big?
Are they supposed to be that big?
I thought they were, like, smaller.
Oh, I didn't realize there was, like, big ruined...
Oh, I didn't realize there was a...
There were big ruined portals here.
Oh.
That's interesting.
Let's see if I can find, like...
Wait, I can't get hurt here, too.
Yes, guys, you...
Oh my god, I found a for...
Wait, this is like...
Wait, I found a fortress, guys.
Oh my god, guys.
We can go to the ender dragon, everyone.
Let's go.
Let's get some blazer eyes and go to the ender.
The fastest fucking fortress find of my life.
Why couldn't it be this easy?
Faster than last time.
Why couldn't it be this easy, guys?
Wait, how am I getting damaged by fire?
Okay, but I can't mine in this world.
How do I get out?
How do I get in?
Can I get in through here?
Oh, I can.
Wow, this is a very peaceful fortress.
I like how nothing spawns here at all.
Wait, I can't even get through this.
There's not even chests or anything.
It just exists to exist.
I'm just naturally...
Oh my god, okay.
Alright, is there anything down here?
Like, there's nothing here but chests.
It's so...
Like, it's so...
Okay, it's a little spooky that like...
It's so quiet.
Oh, there's a chest!
No!
It wouldn't even let me open the chest!
That's so fucked up.
That's actually...
I gotta leave now.
Wait.
I can't leave.
Oh my god, I'm stuck here forever.
Wait.
Wait, it won't let me leave.
Oh my god, I broke the game.
I can't even play my music.
Oh my god, I broke it.
This is my new home.
I don't think I was supposed to be here, guys.
Oh no.
No.
I'm stuck here forever.
They're like, Doki, you do not belong here.
Leave this place now.
Oh.
Guys.
I think I broke the simulation.
I...
Guys.
I think they found out.
I think they found out I went off the grid, guys.
I am the edge of the world.
I found the edge of Minecraft.
I am Doki.
Doki had it again.
I found the edge of the world.
Now where do I...
Wait.
I can't swim up.
I'm stuck down here.
Oh my god.
Wait a minute.
If I...
Can I...
Will it respawn me back in the main menu?
Or am I back in the other world?
This is how I've rested in peace since.
They put me back in...
Oh my god, thank god.
Okay.
That was crazy.
That was a little freaky.
I was actually stuck in the...
I was actually...
I thought I could never leave.
Oh, thanks Jack Black.
How much was the head?
I wanna buy the head.
Rest in peace, Sans.
Alright, where's the...
Okay, it's right over here.
How much is it?
I wanna be a little piglin.
800...
No, I was so close!
Also, what the fuck do we do with this?
Like, do we get a house?
Oh, there's a bucket hat?
Alright, next mission.
Let's go to the next one.
I just wanna be a little piglin.
So I can like...
So I can...
Breach the inner fortress.
I can be like a double agent.
Oh, there's this kid.
From Stranger Things.
He's a Stranger Things kid, right?
We're very low on supplies, so glad you come to bring us back.
It's just a short hop outside the village.
Okay.
Enter wilderness.
He looks like a Stranger Things kid, not gonna lie.
I see child, and I'm like, you must have been from Stranger Things.
Oh, it's to protect the minecart.
Let's check something real quick.
Okay.
Oh wait, I have to reload the...
God damn it!
I tabbed out at the reload!
I forgot!
Bedrock is so weird.
If you tab out...
If you tab out the game, you have to like reload the world.
God damn it.
I wanna check out what that was.
Okay.
I'm fast traveling.
Can't be bothered.
Get me in the wilderness.
I'm not using my legs to walk over there.
That's what not...
That's...
Legs are not meant for that.
That's not what legs are for.
Alright.
No, I missed the tutorial!
No!
What am I supposed to do?
Play my music.
The fuck?
Payload cart.
What am I supposed to do?
What are they doing?
Oh, we're escorting this guy.
If there's two people, does it go faster?
Okay, let's escort them into the piglets.
My bad, guys.
I may have accidentally escorted him to the...
Fuck you.
I'm killing your boyfriend too.
Alright, let's escort it.
Alright, actual intended cart.
Okay.
Oh, so we can go straight ahead.
Oh my god, there's the pillagers.
Get out of here.
Wait, wait a minute.
I might be dying.
Wait, how do I heal?
Oh my god.
Okay, guys.
This will protect me.
I'll use this to body block.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Protecting the cart.
Okay, like, let me look at my quest.
I need Kadoosh.
Which one was Kadoosh?
Okay, cart at least...
Forty...
Three times!
Oh my god, do this three times.
Okay, it's gonna be worth it, guys.
I can Kadoosh it.
Okay, where else would it spawn?
If I move ahead, then I can, like, fight them in advance.
Right?
Or do they, like, spawn in later?
Oh, they, like, spawn in later.
Oh, because they're, like, portals.
Portaling in.
Oh, I see.
That's why everybody was moving ahead.
Okay.
Where else would they go?
Wait, there's a mine here.
Oh my god.
There's $80.
Oh my god, I can wear a pig.
Oh my god, I can wear a piglin hat.
Wait, how do you get an axe?
All I have is a fucking sword.
Wait, is this the end goal?
Yay, we made it!
Yay!
Alright, go, go, go, go.
Faster, faster.
There's two people.
Three on payload, guys!
Three on payload!
Come on, everyone!
If there's more people, there's more payload.
There's more speed.
Guys, I need my kadouche.
Guys.
Oh, fuck.
Wait, there's an actual chicken jockey.
Oh my god, there's an...
Wait, they...
They exist.
Wait, what is he doing in the village?
What is he...
What's that?
What was he doing in the village?
Chicken jockey.
There's a fucking random ass chicken jockey here.
Guys, come on.
Three on payload, guys.
Come on, everybody.
We all know that.
Let me get all...
Let me get...
Wait, wait.
Now I know why there was no one on payload.
Alright, guys.
Let me speed the payload over to the next enemy, guys.
I'm helping.
Guys, I may or may not have not been helping with that.
Okay, the cart's okay.
Alright, guys.
Look at that.
I'm speeding the payload to the next enemy, guys.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, everybody.
Don't let anything...
That's right.
I'm not letting anything stand in my way.
Alright, don't worry.
The payload's here, guys.
The payload's also here again.
Oh, man.
It's so unlucky that there were people dead.
Oh, my God.
There's a chicken jockey.
Alright.
Don't worry, guys.
I got payload duty.
I'm pushing the payload.
I'm on Lucio.
I'm the Lucio cart, baby.
Okay.
Helping.
I need Kadoosh.
I need to Kadoosh it.
Alright.
Move, move, move, move, move, move, move.
Come on.
Move, move, move, move.
Get there.
Alright.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, llamas.
Go.
Come on.
Go, go, go.
Go into the piglins.
I wish, like, the cart can run them over.
What the fuck?
Oh, I completed the quest.
Oh, nice.
Oh, because I killed 200 people.
Can I wear my hat?
Wait, I want to wear my cool hat.
How do I wear it?
Oh, it's in the dressing room.
Oh, I can't because I have my Sans hat.
Apparently, if you have your regular skins, you can't wear hats.
What's the point?
What's the point if I can't even wear a hat on Sans?
Don't worry, I got you.
I got you, llama.
I just need one more.
Come on.
How far is the point?
I'm doing this for Kadoosh.
Oh, wait, we're here.
Nevermind, we did it.
Yippee!
What's the point if we can't be...
I know, right?
What's the point if I can't put a hat on Sans?
Yay!
87.
203!
I did it.
I did that.
Wait, you can earn money from this a lot faster than, uh...
than, like, the other mission.
Yay!
Alright.
Go.
Go do the thing.
Oh, he's AFK.
I just realized I don't actually have to be there to complete the mission.
Oh, what if I kill them from behind?
Do they spawn from behind?
Let me check.
I'm actually curious.
L-l-l-l-lava.
Ch-ch-ch-chicken.
Lava chicken.
I'm checking if anything spawns from behind.
Oh, it doesn't.
Okay, so you have to...
You actually have to, like...
It spawns when the cart is closer or the next enemy or some shit.
I go from the back.
Oh, money!
Money!
Yippee!
Wait, someone... you can die?
Wait, you can die in this game?
How do you die from the Vex?
Where am I?
Okay, this is...
Where did I go in this adventure?
Do you think my cart's okay?
It's fine, right?
Yeah, it should be fine.
Wait, what if I...
Oh, hey.
Are you helping too?
Okay, these portals don't work.
Don't worry, I'm helping!
Don't worry, guys.
Where is the cart?
Where did the cart go?
Wait, guys?
Where is our cart?
Guys?
Oh shit, there's a battle axe?
Wait, that's where you got it?
Wait, I found it.
It's time.
They need you.
Yeah, but where is...
Okay.
I can't help if I don't even know where the cart is, guys.
How am I supposed to help if I don't even know where it is?
Where even am I now?
Okay, this is the base.
Oh, there it is.
Wait, did they fail?
Wait, did you guys fail?
Guys!
No, wait, no, that's...
Oh wait, never mind.
No, that's the NPCs.
Oh, what?
Wait, but where's the cart?
It's all the way here?
Wait, is it the blue line over there?
Guys, where did the cart go?
What?
Oh, is that where the cart is?
How did it get over there?
Okay, I'm heading over.
Don't worry.
I shall be the hero.
Okay, the cart can't be that badly damaged, right?
Alright, I guess it just walked, doki.
Oh my god, it's so far.
Is there anyone still alive over there?
I think I went too far.
Oh see, everybody's fine!
Look at that!
Nothing to worry about and I got battle...
Oh my god, wait.
They have magic now.
Oh shit.
Don't worry, I'm helping.
I'm helping.
Wait, oh my god, they have swords?
What, these tiny guys have swords?
Oh my god!
Okay, this one's a lot harder.
This one's a lot harder.
When did they give them swords?
Look how tiny their swords are!
Look how tiny their fucking swords are!
Oh no.
Oh no, guys.
Guys, this does not look...
Guys, I don't think I'm getting Caduceus.
Guys, I don't think...
Guys, the Vex are destroying our cart.
They upgraded.
Oh my god.
Like, they gave them tiny ass swords.
That's crazy.
You might as well give them a fucking gun.
Oh my god, imagine them holding miniature guns.
Jesus Christ, it hits so hard.
Guys, it's less than 40%.
Let the cart die.
What's the point?
You know, like, when I wasn't there, they were winning, guys.
I should have explored the map a little more.
All I'm
saying is that maybe...
Maybe I shouldn't have come back to help.
All I'm saying is that when I wasn't there, we were winning.
Holy fuck.
Okay, this one is a lot harder.
Like, give me back the easier level.
Okay, who's playing their saxophone?
If I can't play the saxophone, you can't play the saxophone.
Why do we have to start back at the hard level, though?
This level is so hard.
They have, like, guys with mini swords.
My team fucking sucks, man.
We're so far.
I'm leaving.
You know what?
Fuck this.
I'm leaving this team.
You're on your own.
I'm re-rolling my team.
I'm gonna re-roll my team, guys.
All right, go back to the video.
Go back to the village.
This team sucks.
I'm leaving and re-queuing.
Look, my team fucking sucked, okay?
Also, I'm gonna buy the hat.
Doki, you're gonna get a penalty for leaving.
Doki, no!
All right.
You wanna be a villager or...
Oh, my gosh.
A villager or...
A piglin.
No, I'll be a villager.
Guys,
I'm just like him.
Oh, I can buy a guitar.
Wait, why buy an acoustic when I can get a bass guitar?
That's right.
The Sans Jam session right here.
That's where I can start my own band.
Fuck, I need the Cadouche, though.
I'm only...
I just need my cart to, like, survive for one more map.
One more round.
Okay, let's see.
Oh, no, not the quest.
Uh...
Wilderness.
Look, it's a bass guitar, okay, guys?
It's not a...
I know it's a little quiet, but, like...
But, like, it's the little things.
It's the small impact I make.
Wait, I'm back here.
Wait, why is the...
Why am I back in this area?
This level was so fucking hard for Payload.
Oh, my God.
I'm re-rolling.
I'm...
They're never gonna finish this level!
This level is too difficult!
Okay.
It's the same choke point.
Alright, I'll come back later.
That choke point is way too hard.
They have the Vex and those mini-swords fucking hurt.
Alright.
Uh...
I wanna check...
Oh, hey, there's another dog.
Aww.
Oh, he's eating a little bone.
Oh, that's cute.
Okay, where's the one I haven't done?
I've done...
I've done this level.
I've done this one.
Where's the, uh...
Oh, the one back here!
Right?
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Hey, I have one, too.
Let's create a band.
Let's go.
See?
Even through our differences, we can create music to get there.
Oh, my God.
He's holding a balloon like it's fucking Disneyland.
He's like, Yippee!
Minecraft Land!
Yippee!
Happiest place on Earth!
Hehehe.
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
Alright.
Let's see.
I have to head over to...
Oh, my God.
He's just sweeping.
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
Alright, last minigame, guys.
Last one.
What minigame is this one?
Are you the reinforcements?
I'm he...
Oh, wait.
Yeah.
I'll come along.
What do I do here?
It's sweeping time.
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
Alright.
Found a way down into the mine.
We're collecting village defense resources.
Hop on elevators to get different levels.
Oh, my God.
Did you guys hear that the director of Chainsaw Man made a Roblox world?
They made a horror...
I don't know why Roblox.
But, like, they made a horror game.
Yeah.
They made a horror game, Roblox World.
I don't know.
I guess the money paid really well.
I just...
I thought that was absolutely crazy that they actually, like...
I heard, like, Roblox creator can actually make so much fucking money.
Just from like robux and stuff Okay level one No, it's true, okay, I'll play on the stream just random You get like it's it's it's like minecraft movie event and roblox What do we do here?
Instructions unclear.
I'm just in the mines Hello guys.
What are you doing here?
What do we do here?
Do we just exist?
What's our purpose what's our mission Hello You mine oh level two for diamonds, okay I go back Uh Where's the elevator i'm lost again.
Oh, no, i'm stuck Wait, how do I get home?
Oh, it's over here.
Okay, that's where I was Okay level two I want the diamonds
What do I do Is that diamond over there where do I go Does he know what he's doing do I we're just oh my god, you can mine Oh my god, I found diamonds guys Wait, but where's my oh Okay, but what do I get out of it?
Oh my god, there's a creeper lapis Yay I don't even know if i'm supposed to actually mine anything You can mine and you can craft.
Oh my god.
What the fuck is he friendly?
What Oh, who is he trying to kill?
Right Oh, oh he was trying to kill him I was like he seems friendly He was chasing that guy
Guys he wasn't Wait, is it because i'm holding a oh Oh I just realized It's not working.
It's because I don't have a diamond I was like wait Wait a minute, is it because i'm holding it?
But I don't know holy shit is he a good guy hello, are you friendly you want to be
I thought we could be friends Oh my god, oh my god, I pissed him off I missed him Not friend not friend not friend Why can't we be friends why can't we be friend what the fuck am I supposed to make I don't understand this mission I don't understand this world.
I don't know how to get out and return home There's only one way to go home
Oh Oh But like what do I do I return the try to swim and Try to swim in love
I just I don't know what to do Oh, is this iron oh it is Okay, wait, no, it's coal, okay, it looked like iron for some reason Okay, I have iron and coal but what the fuck i'm gonna do with coal in this world
Is there any more iron here Okay, this mini game fucking sucks
I If I want a mine i'll boot up regular minecraft guys, oh I did it yippee But all i'm saying is that if I want a fucking mine, I just boot up regular minecraft Like why am I here Normal mine Like why why did you put me in this world?
Just let me i'll play regular minecraft.
Hey All right back to the lobby mining in my minecraft Because oh you're right I yearn for I was born to be a miner
All right Guys, I don't think i'm gonna get a cape Hello, see you.
All right, maybe maybe the lobby is different now Back to the wilderness.
Are they still stuck in that?
I swear to god if I come back to like this fucking Area, and they're still stuck in that level.
I swear to fucking god Are we in a different oh my god, they're still there they're still oh my god They're still stuck in this area They're still in the
They've never oh my god, they've never progressed through here that's so sad I've i've like left them and they're still in this area.
You can never escape You're stuck here forever I swear to god.
Okay Okay, we can do this There's more of us now.
I'm here now, too Don't worry There's more of us, oh my god, we even have like wait, wait, wait did we did it wait Oh my god, we did.
Oh my I was I was there.
I was part of the team guys I helped Oh my guys, we did it guys Oh my god We fucking did it guys
All right, where's kadouche
Where's kadouche wait, where's kadouche where's my kadouche Where is it?
How do I equip kadouche?
That's the only reason why i'm here All right, let's see wait, how do I get that
Where is my kadouche emote Okay, press b change emote Where is it I own kadouche Oh, I have to go.
Oh I have to reload.
Okay It's gonna be like I swear to god I worked so hard for it
I swear to god don't make me buy kadouche.
Toki just pulled a group Did nothing for a week and took credit for the assignment.
Thank you for the super chat dark queen.
Thank you.
Thank you All right See ya Oh my god, wait, oh my god, wait, no follow over.
Oh, there it is kadouche Okay, we don't need clapping All right, guys
This is it oh wait Sorry, sorry, this is what I I just like that emote a lot.
Sorry, this is it this is it Kadouche
I did it guys.
I can kadouche guys Look Hey lady, you want to see me kadouche watch this Hey there pretty lady Oh, sorry Dude dude, dude Sorry, I need to I need to go to tetris before I kadouche wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, where are you?
Where are you?
Where did you go?
Wait, okay here.
Hey there pretty lady.
Have you ever kadouche before you want to see?
Oh
Guys she didn't want to see
She logged out guys She rejected me wait, hey, what's up?
Wait, oh wait, wait, he left well you want to talk to me?
Supper
When I try to interact I they all leave when I try to talk.
I just want to show them my kadouche Wait fin Stop I want to talk to you What if this is a child and he she's like really creeped out
Fin I want to talk to you fin stop Fin come back here Don't you stop fin come back.
I just I just want to show my kadouche I hope I hope i'm not harassing children Hey fin
Fin no stop I don't worry
I just I just want to show them the cool emote I got Wanna see my kadouche Oh, wait, this is so cool.
Wait, I like this town.
Look at this cool fucking monument over there Oh my god, wait, what is his name?
Mako Hey This is i'm like the only one talking hey you want to see something cool
Watch this Watch this mako Do do do do do.
Who are you?
Just a fella.
Was that cool?
Okay.
He's like, who are you?
Bro, don't talk to strangers.
I just wanted to show him something cool.
They probably thought you were a child.
A child at heart.
Playing a sweet ass bass for this goal.
That's what they all said.
He's like, who are you?
Just a fella.
Just a regular guy.
Average Minecraft YouTuber.
Look, I'm just playing the bass!
I'm trying to hang out with the kids!
I'm just trying to be cool, guys.
I'm just trying to be cool.
I'm sorry, I didn't mean that!
I didn't mean it like that.
Alright, back to the main lobby.
I'm just trying to be hip, guys.
Can I not be cool?
Can I not be cool with the kids?
All I did was show Tetris!
All I did was just Tetris!
What's wrong with Tetris, guys?
Tetris!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, guys.
Guys, you want me to check out the Roblox?
It's a horror map, but I mean, it's fucking Roblox.
The Chainsaw Director guy basically made a Roblox map.
I can check it out right now.
I think I finished the Minecraft.
I'm not getting the cape, guys.
But I get to meet Steve, though.
I met Steve!
Hello, Steve!
Say something, Steve.
Say something funny.
Okay.
Okay, thanks, I guess.
Thanks, Steve.
That was not funny, but okay.
MrBrokenBot, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Classic Minecraft YouTuber.
All I did was show him Tetris!
What's wrong with Tetris?
Wait, what am I doing now?
Autobot.
Kadoosh.
Okay, we were not close to the cape, guys.
We had the...
Okay, we are...
Guys, we were not close.
It was not close at all.
I can only wear this in Bedrock 2.
Yeah, no.
There was no way.
There was no fucking way we could have got that.
All right, I'm gonna Kadoosh my way out of here.
All right, let me look up.
Okay, I need to look up where it is.
I saved it.
I did save it on...
I saved it on Twitter.
So let me check it out real quick.
All right, guys.
It's time.
It's time to play Roblox.
Uh...
Did I save it on Twitter?
Wait, did I not?
No!
I forgot to save it!
Okay, wait.
Let me see if I can find it.
Okay, it's like...
Chainsaw...
Chainsaw Man...
Roblox.
Oh my god.
Oh, here we go.
It was this one.
It's a roguelike...
Oh, it's coming soon!
No!
Wait, is it out now?
Wait.
No!
It's not out yet!
I was so looking forward to it, too.
God damn it.
It's not out yet.
It says coming soon.
I thought it was out now.
Not yet, but there.
This is what it...
is basically the director of Chainsaw Man is literally making a Roblox map right now.
I just think it's funny that at the beginning of the level, you see three Roblox guys.
Three Roblox guys.
Just chilling.
Yeah, that's so...
Why does this look so good?
It's the next generation of gaming, guys.
Roblox.
Okay, log in.
Shit, I don't know what...
Okay, I think this was my...
Is this my username?
I don't remember.
It's been a while.
No!
What's the point if I can't play?
Guys.
What's the point if I can't even...
If I can't even play the scary game I wanted?
You know what I wanna play?
Let's do this one.
Alright.
Since we're playing children games.
Since we're...
Alright.
Let's do this one real quick before we call it here today.
Because I have a second stream later.
Alright, I'm starting Roblox.
Don't worry, I have another good one.
Guys.
I have another good one for you guys.
Do you guys hear it?
The gunshots.
Do you guys hear the gunshots?
You know where we're at right now.
Wait, why is it not showing up?
Oh my god.
Guys, why is my Roblox not capturing, guys?
Is this...
Okay, I remember now.
Okay.
Roblox.
I forgot it requires this.
Don't worry.
By the way, I'm Thomas the Tank Engine now.
Are you five?
Yes, I five.
He's five, guys.
I wanna play.
Let me in.
Let me in, everyone.
I wanna play.
Die.
Please.
I could've saved you.
Please, just die.
I wanna join the games.
I'm actually five dudes in a trench coat.
Oh, wait.
Waiting for players.
Wait, that's me.
That's me.
I'm players.
Wait, that's me.
Let me in.
Oh, no.
They're waiting for these guys.
They're all still alive?
Kill them.
Oh, yeah.
How do they get in?
How do we get in?
Oh, the game started in 40 seconds.
Alright, guys.
Oh my...
What?
Why are you so tall?
Wait.
There's like...
There's like sexy Roblox characters.
Why is she so tall?
You know, I'm on my cousin's...
Wait.
I didn't see how many people.
I...
Oh.
How many...
Oh my god.
I'm getting pushed.
How many people?
How many people, guys?
I didn't see.
I didn't see how many people were supposed to be in here.
How many people?
I didn't see.
How many?
Two.
Oh.
Oh my god.
We are not working together.
We are absolutely...
Oh, I'm dead.
I am dead.
Oh, I am so dead.
Let's all die together.
Goodbye, everybody.
Yes.
I have enough.
I'm going back in.
I did it.
Yippee.
What the fuck, Happy Froggy?
I did it, guys.
But I won't be next to this man.
He seems pretty boring again.
Yeah.
Oh, three players.
Three players.
We can work together.
You, me.
There we go.
Look at that.
We're so good at working together, guys.
Okay, but like...
Wait, okay.
You can apparently push people out, too.
Oh, I...
You have to buy that.
Look, I did it.
I see where you're looking.
What do you mean?
I'm just walking around.
I'm just chilling with my homies.
Yeah, me and...
Me and Faceless Girl here.
And Kiki.
Okay, how do I talk to people?
Can you...
What?
Let's team.
Okay, I shouldn't.
There's children.
I...
I know there's actual children here.
I should not talk to anyone in this lobby.
I should not...
No, we are not...
I don't have Kadoosh here.
Hello, Happy Froggy.
Okay, this guy cannot be a child.
I refuse to believe Happy Froggy is a child.
He is a grown adult like me trying to...
Oh my god, okay.
1, 2, 3, 4...
Okay, that's not...
Guys, we don't know how to count.
1, 2...
We're counting.
1, 2, 3, 4...
Okay, that's not enough.
2, 4...
There's not enough.
2, 4, 6, 7...
Wait.
I can't!
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7...
Oh.
We're 8.
Oh my god, no!
Don't bully Happy Froggy!
He's just a...
Oh, but get out!
So, we have 8.
We good.
Okay, but what if I just open...
Sorry.
I'm closing it when there was...
Oh no.
Oh no, he is a child.
Oh.
Oh no.
Froggy...
Let's stand away from Froggy.
This can't be a child.
These can't be...
These is not a child, I can tell.
Oh dear.
They're cute.
Maybe he's just like me.
I saw what he wrote and I was like, yeah, no.
That's a child.
The face isn't helping.
We're 4, we're 4, we're 4.
Oh, nice.
That's right.
Look at that.
Wait, what?
We're 4.
Wait, we need 2 more.
There we go, we're 4 now.
Okay, let's go.
Wait, I like that other guy.
That guy doesn't seem like a child.
Like, he had the...
You know, the flip-flip from Wicked.
Oh no.
Wait, no.
Guys, I feel...
I feel weird having Thomas the Tank Engine.
I'm gonna hide in this corner.
I...
Let me...
I feel weird now.
Now that I'm like, oh man.
There's not a lot of meme avatars in here.
I feel like a little creepier.
I'm gonna hide my Thomas in this corner.
Okay.
Thomas, no.
I'm not gonna...
I'm not gonna show this.
I think these are actually children.
I think it!
Oh my god.
Okay, 6.
6.
Okay.
Oh.
I guess we die.
2.
Guys, there's not...
There's not...
There's only 4 of us.
There's only...
Guys.
This is it.
There's only 4 of us.
Oh no.
We die.
Goodbye!
He's just...
He's just stretching.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm gonna leave this lobby.
I'm gonna...
I think I have to leave this lobby, guys.
Okay.
Okay, let's...
Let's...
Yeah, this...
I feel a little awkward in this lobby, guys.
He's like...
Alright, well...
That was fun.
That...
That was fun, guys.
Not that key.
Not the Roblox key.
But the Minecraft key was fun, guys.
The Minecraft...
It was nice checking out what the...
Let me swap scenes real quick.
The Minecraft movie event.
I had a fun time checking that out.
My brain has finally kickstarted itself.
So, like, I should be good for the sponsor stream tonight.
By the way, for those who don't know...
Wait!
I can unlock it in Java?
Okay, I'll do that later.
I still have, like, 3 more days.
Bro, that shit is a grind.
That shit is actually a fucking grind.
There's like...
Like, I have to do all the...
Oh my god.
I'll do that later.
I'm not gonna fucking...
I'm not gonna finish that on stream.
There's too many quests.
Oh, gosh.
That was interesting.
Yeah, grinding in Minecraft?
I'd rather just play Rivals.
I'm not gonna be grinding any fucking game.
Yeah, from Minecraft...
From Marvel Rivals grind to Minecraft grind.
Yeah, it's like...
Guys, I need a little rest from that.
Hey, guys.
I had a great time.
I always have a great time with you guys.
I hope you have a great time watching, everybody.
It was a very, like, random low-energy type stream.
But...
Right now, I'm not okay at the moment.
I'm honestly...
I'm honestly not okay right now.
I am...
The blood moon is going strong right now.
But...
But I hope you guys enjoyed today's stream.
I do have another stream later tonight.
I'll be watching a...
The Call of Duty draft day.
I don't know what the drafting is at the moment.
I don't really know what the draft day is.
I assume they're, like...
I assume it's just picking teammates and, like, seeing, like, which...
Categorizing teammates into teams or something?
I don't know.
I'll read the briefing later.
I'll read the sponsor briefing later.
But please support the Twitch stream later tonight.
It really helps a lot.
They picked me and a couple of other really big streamers for it.
So, I would really appreciate if you guys can hop down for the stream and just hang out with me while we watch the draft day.
Hey, guys.
I hope you had a great time watching.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture checked, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you didn't stay up for me, head to bed or come to the sponsor stream tonight on Twitch.
It's not food time.
It's Walkie's time, by the way.
It's actually not food time.
It's just Walkie times.
Anyway, I'll see you guys later, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!
He always knows when I'm ending.
I don't know how.